The Amazing Audie Murphy
Audie Murphy was born on June 20, 1925 in
Texas.
His family was extremely poor, partially due
to having twelve young mouths to feed.
When his father abandoned the family when
Audie was fifteen years old, he was forced
to pick up some of the slack by hunting and
doing what work he could to keep food on the
table.
Unfortunately, his mother died just a year
after his father left.
Shortly thereafter, when the Japanese attacked
Pearl Harbor, Audie attempted to join the
various branches of the U.S. military but
was turned down in each case owing to his
age and diminutive stature -five and a half
feet tall (1.66 meters) and weighing only
about 100 pounds (45 kg).
About seven months later, just ten days after
he turned seventeen, he tried again.
Having gained some weight (getting up to a
whopping 112 pounds / 50.8 kg) and with falsified
testimony from his sister claiming he was
actually 18, this time Audie was able to get
into the army.
He was then shipped off to North Africa and
later deployed to Sicily.
Despite his small size, Murphy proved to be
a phenomenal soldier.
In 1944, after witnessing the death of a friend
during Operation Dragoon, he charged a group
of German soldiers, took over their machine
guns and other weapons, and proceeded to take
out the other enemy soldiers within range
using their own artillery.
He was awarded a Distinguished Service Cross
for his actions that day, the first of many
medals.
During another battle shortly after this,
to cover retreating Allied soldiers, he jumped
onto a tank that had been hit and was on fire,
exposing himself to the advancing enemy soldiers.
Why did he put himself in such an exposed
position on a tank that could potentially
explode at any minute?
There was a .50 caliber machine gun on the
tank.
As Private Anthony Abramski said of the event,
“It was like standing on top of a time bomb
… he was standing on the TD chassis, exposed
to enemy fire from his ankles to his head
and silhouetted against the trees and the
snow behind him.”
Nevertheless, over the course of the next
hour, he held off six German tanks and several
waves of enemy soldiers, who were all trying
desperately to take out the little American
who was the only thing in their way at that
point.
He only retreated when he ran out of ammo.
Once this happened, having sustained a leg
wound and completely exhausted, Audie said
in his book To Hell and Back,
“I slide off the tank destroyer and, without
once looking back, walk down the road through
the forest.
If the Germans want to shoot me, let them.
I am too weak from fear and exhaustion to
care.”
Despite the leg wound, as soon as he caught
up with his retreating soldiers who had now
re-formed, he turned them around and managed
to reclaim a stretch of forest from German
occupation.
According to the official report, in that
battle, he killed or severely wounding at
least fifty German soldiers by himself.
For this act of bravery and for “indomitable
courage and his refusal to give an inch of
ground [saving] his company from possible
encirclement and destruction…” he was
awarded the U.S. Medal of Honor.
He rose through the ranks and was a captain
when he was pulled out of the war in 1945.
All in all, he earned 33 awards and decorations
for his exemplary service during the war.
He was just 20 years old at the time and,
as one movie critic later put it, knew more
of death than he did of life.
When Murphy returned from the war, he suffered
from post-traumatic stress disorder, a condition
that often went undiagnosed at the time.
After being featured on the cover of Life
magazine, he found himself in Hollywood without
work, sleeping in rough conditions.
He caught his big break in 1949 when he starred
in the film Bad Boy.
That same year, he released the aforementioned
autobiography titled To Hell and Back, which
topped the bestseller charts.
He went on to star as himself in a movie with
the same title in 1955; it was Universal’s
top-grossing film for nearly 20 years until
Jaws usurped it.
Acting seemed to suit him.
He made no less than 44 feature films while
he was in Hollywood, many of them westerns,
and also filmed a 26-episode western TV series
called Whispering Smith, which aired in 1961
on NBC.
It was criticised for being too violent, however,
and cancelled after just 20 episodes were
aired.
A man of many talents, Murphy also dabbled
in poetry and song-writing as well as horse
breeding and racing.
Thanks to his earnings from acting, he was
able to purchase a ranch in Texas.
He was living an incredibly comfortable life,
far grander than what he had known as a child.
Yet all was not well with Murphy.
Back to his post traumatic stress disorder,
he became dependent on sleeping pills to combat
the insomnia he experienced after the war.
Realizing he had become addicted to them,
he locked himself in a motel room for a week,
while he worked through the withdrawal symptoms.
He ended up beating the addiction and went
on to break the taboo of talking about the
mental disorders many soldiers suffered when
they returned home.
His willingness to do so opened up discussions
about psychological care for veterans upon
their return to the US.
Murphy ended up marrying twice, divorcing
his first wife after just two years, and having
two sons with his second wife.
He appeared to be happy with his family, with
more than enough money in the bank to keep
them comfortable (though he squandered much
of it on gambling in his later years); had
acted in dozens of movies; and had amazing
war stories to tell his grandkids about.
Unfortunately, he wasn’t able to get to
that stage of his life.
On May 28, 1971, Murphy was in a private plane
flying on a business trip from Atlanta, Georgia
to Martinsville, Virginia.
The weather conditions were less than ideal:
rain and fog shortened the pilot’s visibility
considerably, and he had a questionable instrument
rating.
He called in to the Roanoke, Virginia airport
to say that he would be landing shortly due
to poor conditions.
The plane, carrying five passengers including
Murphy, never landed in the Roanoke Valley.
It crashed into Brush Mountain twenty miles
away, close to Blacksburg.
Everyone in the crash was killed.
Murphy was just 45 years old.
The site of the crash has since been turned
into a monument, and in the 1990s, the Appalachian
Trail was rerouted to go past it.
That wasn’t quite the end for Murphy, though.
After a funeral in Arlington Cemetery, where
his grave remains the second most visited
(after Kennedy’s), he was posthumously awarded
his final medal, the Texas Legislative Medal
of Honor.
It was presented to his last remaining sister,
Nadine Murphy, on October 29, 2013 by Governor
Rick Perry.